hey 42 here one in five marriages in the
world are between first cousins welcome
to RIF the founders of hewlett-packard
flipped a coin to decide which of them
would come first in the company name the
facial expressions unlike Oh figures
have become increasingly more angry over
the last thirty years a quarter of
philosophers believe in zombies
alligators balance twigs on their noses
two lovebirds looking for nest building
materials one in three children today
can use a tablet before they can speak
wine can be artificially aged by passing
it through an electric field for three
minutes John Lennon and George Harrison
once got a bus across Liverpool to visit
a man who could teach them the chord b7
Tosh's was a name for men who earned a
living by searching London sewers for
lost valuables an elephant's call can be
heard anywhere within a hundred square
miles
by 2050 70 percent of people will live
in cities the Pinstripe on a rolls-royce
is hand painted with no margin for error
as the painter special properties which
make it instantly bond to the underlying
car paint the job is reserved for one
man only mark caught his sole job is to
paint that pinstripe on every new
rolls-royce one out of ten passwords
used on the Internet are either password
one two three four five six or one two
three four five six seven eight a
newborn baby sucks in air with 50 times
the power of an adult people eating in a
group of seven or more eats twice as
much as people eating alone it takes 700
grapes to make one bottle of wine thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you